نبدأ اليوم بقيادة عالمنا في
البحث المحموم عن ناجين بعد
الزلزال المدمر الذي أودى حتى الآن
بحياة أكثر من 3400 شخص ، وهو عدد لا
يزال يتزايد بشكل مأساوي على
ما يبدو كل ساعة ، حيث ضرب الزلزال الذي بلغت قوته 7.8 درجة
تركيا وسوريا في
وقت سابق من هذا الصباح.
جهود الإنقاذ تجعل الأمور أكثر
صعوبة ، بعض المناطق تخضع
لتحذيرات الطقس الشتوي للثلوج والرياح
العاتية ودرجات الحرارة المنخفضة للغاية
الرئيس التركي أردوغان اليوم مناشدًا
الدول الأخرى لإرسال
فرق البحث والإنقاذ الأكثر خبرة.
حتى فكرة تقريبية عن عدد
الأشخاص المفقودين الآن المحاصرين
تحت هذه الأكوام العملاقة من الخرسانة ومقاطع
الفيديو الملتوية الملتوية التقطت لحظة
انهيار هذا المبنى في وسط
تركيا اليوم ، وكان هذا أحد
أقوى الزلازل التي ضربت المنطقة
منذ أكثر من مائة عام  الآن
كانت هناك بعض اللحظات من Hope اليوم ،
هذا الفيديو الذي نشرته
مجموعة متطوعة من الخوذ البيضاء يظهر رجال الإنقاذ وهم يسحبون
الصبي الصغير من مأزق مزدوج في
شمال غرب سوريا ، تبدأ قناة CNN كراتشي
تغطيتنا اليوم من
إسطنبول تركيا حيث
أعلن قادة البلاد  أسبوع من
التحذير الوطني نريد أن نحذرك بالطبع ،
قد يكون من الصعب مشاهدة بعض هذه المواد
بعد لحظات ، قام
طاقم تلفزيوني تركي بالإبلاغ مباشرة أثناء
صنع مشهد مروع ، حيث
يلتقط المراسل فتاة صغيرة بينما
يستقر الأنقاض والدخان من حولهم
لإنقاذهم.  بدأت الجهود على الفور
في جنوب تركيا ، حيث قام شاب بحبس
اليأس في عينيه ، ثم في
ظلمة ما قبل الفجر ، لحظة فرح
انتزعت من تحت الأنقاض ، كان هذا
مبنى سكنيًا مليئًا بالعائلات
النائمة في منازلهم عندما
ضرب الزلزال العنيف ثم كنت نائمًا.
عندما أيقظتني زوجتي فجأة ،
كان الزلزال شديدًا مخيفًا للغاية ، فقد استغرق الأمر
ما يقرب من دقيقتين حتى توقف الاهتزاز
مع مرور الساعات من قبل المزيد من عمليات الإنقاذ ،
وبدأت المستشفيات أيضًا في تجاوز
الوفيات المبلغ عنها والتي ترتفع بالمئات
كل ساعة ، وتأثر الملايين
في سوريا الأب.  يبكي على
جسد طفله الذي يعرج العديد من الأطفال من بين القتلى
والجرحى من
غير الواضح كم عدد الذين ما زالوا
محاصرين وعدد الذين فقدوا حياتهم
ولكن أه
الخوذ البيضاء فعلت ذلك قبل أن
يسحب أبطال الحرب الأهلية السورية الناس الآن من تحت وطأة الحرب الأهلية السورية.
كارثة مختلفة جدًا لدرجة أن الكثيرين في ريفيل اعتقدوا أن
شمال سوريا لم يكن لديهم سوى القليل جدًا بالأمس ، حيث لن
يترك الناس أي شيء اليوم
في تركيا 2 ستكون هناك حاجة للمساعدة الخارجية
قادة العالم الذين تعهدوا بالفعل
ونشر فرق الإنقاذ ،
وسيستمر البحث والإنقاذ لعدة أيام.
بقدر الإمكان ،
تستمر عمليات البحث والإنقاذ الخاصة بي ، أنا جيك ، حتى الليل ، لكنهم
يتعاملون مع
ظروف صعبة حقًا في الوقت الحالي ، بالطبع ، لقد أدى Nightfall إلى
إبطاء عمليات البحث والإنقاذ
لديك ، حيث كان الطقس
يتجمد ويتساقط عليك الثلج.  لدينا طرق
مسدودة وبعد ذلك حصلت على
هذه الهزات الارتدادية القوية أكثر من 130
وفقًا للمسؤولين الأتراك مما
يجعل هذا الأمر صعبًا للغاية بالنسبة
لهم وبما أن المجتمع الدولي
يسارع إلى تزويد تركيا
بالمساعدة والدعم الذي طلبته أه
الناس في  شمال غرب سوريا في منطقة
ريفيل التي تسيطر عليها أجزاء من شمال
سوريا يدعو بشدة
المجتمع الدولي أه قائلاً ألا
ننسى هؤلاء السكان الذين
مروا بالكثير من جاي لأنك
تعرف على مر السنين والناس هناك ليس
لديهم أي شيء على الإطلاق وهم يقرؤون
حقًا  بحاجة إلى كل المساعدة والدعم الذي
يمكنهم الحصول عليه الآن. jamana karacha في
إسطنبول تركيا ، شكرًا جزيلاً على
انضمامك إلينا الآن هو Khan saunner مع
الهلال الأحمر التركي الذي يعد جزءًا من
الصليب الأحمر الدولي خان ، شكرًا
لانضمامك إلينا ما هي أكبر الاحتياجات على  في
الوقت الحالي ،
نعم ، بصفتنا جمعية التعليم التركية ،
نركز بشكل كبير على تغطية
الاحتياجات الأساسية مثل البطانيات
وتوفير الأطعمة لأننا في
المرحلة الأولى من الاستجابة لذلك
نحاول حماية الناس من
فصل الشتاء القاسي  هذا هو السبب في أننا
نرسل البطانيات
وغيرها من المواد غير الغذائية من مخزوننا
إلى المنطقة المتضررة كما تعلم ، أعني أن
المنطقة تتكون من 10 مقاطعات لذلك
نقوم بتفريق فرقنا لإرسال
هذه المواد الإغاثية وهم الآن
يوزعون  للناس
لمشاهدينا الذين قد لا يكونون على
دراية بهذه المنطقة ، ما الذي يمكنك
إخبارنا به عن المناطق
الأكثر تضررًا
نعم أرياس من الصعب رؤية أرياس
هي مقاطعة ماراش
وأيضًا هناك مناطق أخرى تأثرت
بالزلزال وهذه  المناطق المحيطة
بمحافظة ماراش أعني بشكل أساسي أن هذه المناطق
جبلية
والارتفاع مرتفع
وظروف الشتاء قاسية جدًا ولهذا السبب
وقت الزلزال لا تعلم أنه لا
يسمح لك بمعرفة عمليات الاستجابة المناسبة
لذلك هذا هو الأهم
الصعوبة التي واجهناها الآن ،
كيف تبدو عملية الاسترداد على المدى القصير
وكيف تبدو عملية الاسترداد طويلة المدى
بالطبع أه ولدينا
نهج هجين في ذلك أولاً وقبل كل شيء نحن الآن في
البداية نحاول إكمال
استجابة أولية أه مرحلة بعد ذلك
سنركز على بعض
المساعدات النقدية أعتقد مع
حكومتنا أه طبعا نحن
نكمل جهود
الحكومة في احتواء تأثير
الاستجابة لكن على المدى الطويل
سنذهب إلى أه من  بالطبع سوف
نركز ، لقد
فقدنا للتو أه سلبيات إفادة سارنر ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك
ولهلال الأحمر الدولي